hey guys it is Friday again which means
I've got five of this week's best
stories in gaming all ready to go for
you here's what's been going on some
clever destiny players uncovered a
secret mission in the taken King which
yields a pretty awesome reward a secret
area in the game's lost to light mission
rewards you with the black spindle apart
from having a sweet name it's an exotic
sniper rifle which is reminiscent of the
black hammer gun from Destiny's doc for
low expansions players trying to get
their hands on the sweet gun need to
move very quickly to find the secret
area within the missions escape routes
and then kill off all the enemies in the
room in ten minutes for the full rundown
on how to pick up the black spindle
check out our walkthrough on GameSpot
[Music]
Lionhead Studios has confirmed that
fable school is not in development in
replying to a fan query the developer
tweeted we're not working on fable for
fable legends is our priority and will
be for the foreseeable future fable
legends is coming to Xbox one and PC and
Lionhead have said the game will support
cross-platform play the devs have said
they will support the RPG with a
constant stream of DLC for a period of
up to 10 years this week in Cheaper
games Xbox has announced a bunch of new
zeal swith goals Xbox 360 owners can
pick up games including Battlefield Bad
Company 2 and Devil May Cry 4 for 5
bucks you can also get battlefield 3
battlefield 4 and alien isolation for
less than $20 if you've got an Xbox one
you may want to get your hands on cheap
copies of Batman Arkham Knight for $42
or DMC Devil May Cry definitive edition
for 24 bucks for the full list of deals
head to our story on GameSpot the PC has
been overtaken as the top gaming
platform for kids according to a new
report from the NPD group the MPD's
latest kids and gaming report which
explores what platforms children aged 2
to 17 play most has unveiled that mobile
is now leading the pack sixty-three
percent of the children surveyed
reported regularly playing on mobile
devices while 45 percent said they used
a home computer that's down 22 percent
from 2013 console gaming has also
declined in popularity although it is
still popular between the 9 to 11 age
group with 41 percent reporting
regularly playing games on console
platforms
a rollercoaster tycoon world video drops
this week showing off a bunch of new
gameplay new features include enhanced
AI a terrain defamation tool Steam
Workshop support and a more flexible
coaster editor which promises to not
have you building a roller coaster
piece-by-piece like many of us did in
the first game before running out of
money and patience halfway through Atari
also announced their collaboration with
Six Flags which gives the devs access to
real world data like parks schematics
and coaster designs the game was
originally supposed to be out earlier
this year but fan criticism of the games
visuals prompted a change in art style
away from its cartoonish look let me
know down in that comment section what
you cared about this week and what you
think of the new roller coaster tycoon
world gameplay this week on site I cover
you off on five of the best expansions
ever on the gist Lucy tells you about
this year's best sci-fi and we try out
FIFA 16 that is everything I have feed
this week as always be sure to have
yourself a lovely weekend and I will
catch you again on Monday